loving this new record I appreciate it
you mustard and Dirk shout out to my
brothers
um it's been a minute since we dropped
and uh we back back like we never left
it is interesting that like you guys are
doing a joint album together which feels
like overdue
I can uh I could see that it feels like
you know there should have been like
this like I don't know seven years ago
or something but maybe yeah but we're
doing it now you know
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter you
know the record is here the record is
here it's one of the greatest records
that you're gonna hear and uh
I can't wait for you to hear man I was
gonna say timing wise like why was it
like you know what Now's the Time like
let's do it let's get together let's do
a whole [ __ ] album you know God's
Thomas
that's why yeah that's why you know
God's time you want God's timing I'm an
atheist so I don't know but you know
guys tell me whether you want to believe
it or not yeah hello hello how many
records
uh enough just the perfect amount not
one of those albums that have all these
records for streams trying to cheat you
know I'm saying you either Gonna Love it
or you're not so it's one of them ones
you'll see like God there's 27 something
yeah cheating y'all cheating make an
actual good album yeah how about no
filler all bangers let's go body of work
let's go yeah oh man that's what I'm
talking about you're one of the I do
feel like when it comes to bodies of
work though you're one of the most
consistent artists at least in my
opinion when I know if you drop a
project it would even go to the mixtape
days like I just know that there's I
could just press play that means a lot
my brother I appreciate it yeah even the
last album uh there was like
there was like some stuff that I feel
like uh when the album came out it was
amazing but there were so many records
that didn't make that last project yeah
that you had played me yeah that's a
whole nother yeah we ended up making a
whole nother album last minute
just because I was having fun in the
studio and that's the one I decided to
go with and the division album was dope
thank you I appreciate that as well
shout out to my brother Daniel shout out
to uh 85 I just seen him out in Miami
they got a new album that's about the
job I think yeah it comes out next week
I think oh that's gonna be crazy
don't never want to send the album early
I don't know what's up with that but
send that thing I love how they got in
with JD and like I'm like I'm hearing
these songs and I'm like this [ __ ]
reminds me of like 99 r b which is a
good thing by the way yeah I mean that's
what I feel like R B has been missing
everybody got lazy with it so when you
get artists like division you know going
crazy brim fires going crazy
uh myself of course
it's a couple week a name for sure it's
doing it but you know that's a good
thing for sure 100 shout out to JD 100
shot JD uh for you though what has been
like was there any sort of like
creative difference for you honing in
with one producer for a whole project or
was it kind of did it make it easier was
it more difficult was it did it change
your process at all
when I'm working with mustard it's like
my you know he's my brother you know I'm
saying we started in this [ __ ] together
so it's like working with if it was me
and you working on some [ __ ] you guys
are like on magazine covers and [ __ ]
together you guys are very synonymous
with each other so it was it was easy
it was easy man just his ideas my ideas
back and forth back and forth it was
quick you know
the actual time we spent in the studio
how long did it like if you had a guess
estimate like how long did it take for
you to know it didn't take more than a
month to knock it out but just spend
over time due to his schedule and my
schedule wow do you get first like dibs
over the beats
for sure
he gave me all this fire [ __ ] and then I
was giving him you know ideas Melodies
with vocals and then he'll add his parts
to it and we're just going back and
forth like that so it was crazy yeah I
was whenever I'm talking about you in
interviews I always say that creatively
you're a genius I appreciate it man
you're historically one of the more
slept on artists somehow of our time I
don't like that slept on [ __ ] I'm one of
the greatest artists of our time so
y'all got to stop saying that [ __ ]
you're a genius stop pushing that
narrative Ty Dolla Sign one of the best
y'all ever heard I agree fully
um are we are we oh we're going chain
we're chaining them hey let me just hold
one can I hold one can you light one and
just let me hold it
let me just soak up some of that [ __ ]
cans you know what I mean
for people who don't know you're not
like a regular smoker but these are
special these are special I don't know
why I'm going so fast on them right now
I got a ration these things out I'm
gonna just take one pool just to keep it
lit
that's the first time I've ever smoked a
cigarette actually when I was eight did
you you got to bite that first one a
little Tangy part
no you're gonna hear it
look at it you see the little orange
part that's not I'm not comfortable with
anymore all right here you go yeah
wait wait when did Dwight get here what
the [ __ ] I got both we got both Atlantic
reps in this [ __ ] oh man it's
special man we out here come on do you
bringing them out I'm going number one
you're bringing them out